welcome to cs224n uh lecture
seven
teen
uh model analysis and explanation
okay look at us we're here um
uh let's start with some course
logistics um we have uh updated the
policy on the guest lecture reactions um
they're all due friday um all at 11 59
pm you can't use late days for this
uh so please get the men
um watch the lectures they're awesome
lectures they're awesome guests um and
you get something like half a point for
each of them and yeah all three can be
submitted up through friday
um okay so uh final projects remember
that the due date is tuesday
it's tuesday at 4 30 p.m uh march 16th
and
let me uh emphasize that there's a hard
deadline on the three days from then
friday
we won't be accepting for additional
points off
assignments i'm sorry final projects
that are submitted after
the 4 30 deadline on friday
uh we need to get these graded and get
grades in so um
it's the end stretch week nine our week
10 is
really the lectures are
us giving you help on the final project
so so this is really the last week of
lectures thanks for all your hard work
um and for asking awesome questions in
lecture and in office hours and on ed
and let's get let's get right into it so
um today we get to talk about one of my
favorite subjects in natural language
processing it's model analysis and
explanation um so first we're going to
do what i love doing which is motivating
why we want to talk about the topic at
all
we'll talk about how you know we can
look at a model at different levels of
abstraction to perform different kinds
of analysis on it
we'll talk about out-of-domain
evaluation sets so this will feel
familiar to the to the robust qa folks
um
then we'll talk about uh sort of trying
to figure out for a given example why
did it make the decision that it made it
had some input it produced some output
can we come up with some sort of
interpretable explanation for it
and um then
we'll look at actually the
representations of the models so these
are the sort of hidden states the
vectors that are being built you know
throughout the processing of the model
try to figure out if we can understand
some of the representations and
mechanisms that the model is performing
and then we'll actually come back to
sort of one of the kind of default
states that we've been in in this course
which is
trying to you know look at model
improvements removing things from models
seeing how it performs and relate that
to the analysis that we're doing in this
lecture show how it's not all
all that different
uh okay
um so
if you haven't seen this xkcd um now you
have and it's one of my favorites i'm
going to say all the words so uh person
a says this is your machine learning
system person b says yup you pour the
data into this big pile of linear
algebra and then collect the answers on
the other side
person a what if the answers are wrong
and person b just stir the pile until
they start looking right
and i feel like at its worst deep
learning can feel like this from time to
time you have a model
maybe it works for some things maybe it
doesn't work for other things
you're not sure why it works for some
things and doesn't work for others and
you know the changes that we make to our
models
you know they're based on intuition but
frequently you know what are the tas
told you know everyone in office hours
like ah sometimes you just have to try
it and see if it's going to work out
because it's very hard to tell um it's
very very difficult
to understand our models on sort of any
level and so today we'll go through a
number of ways for trying to sort of
carve out little bits of understanding
here and there um so so uh
beyond it being you know
important because it's in the next kcd
comic
what why should we care about what our
models about understanding our models
one is that we want to know
what our models are doing
so
here you have a black box
black box functions are sort of this
idea that you can't look into them and
interpret what they're doing
you have an input sentence say and then
some output prediction
maybe this black box is actually your uh
your final project uh model and it gets
some accuracy
now
we summarize our models and in your
final projects you'll summarize your
model with sort of one or a handful of
of summary metrics of accuracy or f1
score or bluescore or something
but
it's a lot of model to explain with just
a small number of metrics so what do
they learn why do they succeed and why
do they fail
what's another motivation so we want to
we want to sort of know what our models
are doing okay but but uh maybe that's
because we want to be able to make
tomorrow's model so today
right when you're building models in
this class at the company you know you
start out with some kind of recipe that
is
known to work either at the company or
because you have experience from this
class um and it's not perfect right it
makes mistakes you look at the errors
and then over time you know you take
what works
maybe
and then you find what needs changing so
it seems like maybe you know adding
another layer to the model helped uh and
maybe that's that's a nice tweak and the
model performance gets better etc
and um you know incremental progress
doesn't always feel exciting but i want
to pitch to you that it's actually very
important for us to understand how much
incremental progress can kind of get us
towards some of our goals
so that we can have a better job of
evaluating when we ne when we need big
leaps when we need major changes because
there are problems that we're attacking
with our incremental sort of progress
and we're not getting very far
okay so we want to make tomorrow's model
um another thing that's i think very
related to and sort of a
both a part of and bigger than this
field of analysis is
model biases so let's say you take your
word to vect uh analogies solver you
know from um
from glove
or word to back that is from assignment
one and you give it the the analogy
managed to computer programmer as woman
is two and it gives you the output
homemaker this is a real example from
the paper uh below
um
you should be like wow well uh
i'm glad i know that now and of course
you saw the lecture
from yulia svetkov
last week you said wow i'm glad i know
that now and that's a that's a huge
problem what did the model use in its
decision what biases is it learning from
data and possibly making even worse
so
that's the kind of thing you can also do
with model analysis beyond just making
models better according to some sort of
summary metric
as well and then another thing we don't
just want to make tomorrow's model and
this is something that i think is super
important uh we
you know
we don't just want to look at that time
scale we want to say what about 10 15 25
years from now what kinds of things will
we be doing you know what are the limits
what can be learned by language model
pre-training
what are the what's the model that will
replace the transformer
what's the model that will replace that
model
what does deep learning struggle to do
what are we sort of attacking over and
over again and failing to make
significant progress on what do neural
models tell us about language
potentially there's some people who are
primarily interested in understanding
language better using neural networks
cool
how are
how are our models affecting people
transferring power between groups of
people governments etc that's an
excellent type of analysis what can't be
learned via language model pre-training
so that's sort of the complementary
question there if you sort of come to
the edge of what you can learn via
language model pre-training is there
stuff that we need total paradigm shifts
in order to to uh
to do well
so all of this i mean you know falls
under some category of trying to really
deeply understand our models and their
capabilities
and
there's a lot of different methods here
that we'll go over today and one thing
that i want you to take away from it is
that they're all
[Applause]
they're all going to tell us
some aspect of the model elucidate some
kind of intuition or something but none
of them are are we going to say aha i
really understand 100 about what this
model is doing now um so they're going
to provide some clarity but never total
clarity and
one way if you're trying to decide how
you want to understand your model more
i think you should sort of start out by
thinking about is at what level of
abstraction do i want to be looking at
my model so
the sort of very high level abstraction
let's say you trained you know a qa
model to estimate the probabilities of
start and end indices and you know in a
reading comprehension problem or you've
trained a language model that assigns
probabilities to words in context you
can just look at the model as that
object so it's just a probability
distribution defined by your model
you are not looking into it any further
than the fact that you can sort of give
it inputs and see what outputs it
provides
so that's like
not even who even cares if it's a neural
network it could be anything
but it's a way to understand its
behavior
another level of abstraction that you
can look at you can dig a little deeper
you can say well i know that my network
is a bunch of layers that are kind of
stacked on top of each other you've got
sort of maybe your transformer encoder
with your one layer two layer three
layer you can try to see what it's doing
as it goes deeper in the layers
so maybe your neural model is a sequence
of these vector representations a third
option of sort of specificity is to look
you know as much as as at as much detail
as you can you've got these parameters
in there you've got the connections in
the computation graph
so now you're sort of trying to remove
all of the abstraction that you can and
look at as many details as possible and
all three of these sort of ways of
looking at your model and performing
analysis
are going to be useful and will actually
sort of travel
slowly from one to two to three as we go
through this lecture
okay
so we haven't actually talked about any
analyses yet
uh so we're going to get started on that
on that now um
and we're starting with the sort of
testing our model's behaviors
so would we want to see will my model
perform well i mean the the natural
thing to ask is how does it behave on
some on some sort of
test set
right and so uh we don't really care
about mechanisms yet why is it
performing this by what method is it
making its decision instead we're just
interested in sort of the more higher
level abstraction
of like does it perform the way i want
it to perform so so let's like take out
take our model evaluation that we are
already doing and sort of recast it in
the framework of analysis so you've
trained your model on some samples
from some distribution so you've got
input output pairs of some kind
so how does the model behave on samples
from the same distribution that's a
simple question and it's sort of uh
you know it's known as you know the
in-domain accuracy or
you can say that the samples are iid and
that's what you're testing on and this
is just
what we've been doing this whole time
it's your test set accuracy or f1 or
blue score
and you know um so
you've got some model with some accuracy
and
maybe it's better than some model with
some other accuracy on this test set
right so this is what you're doing as
you're iterating on your models in your
final project as well um
you say well you know on my test set
which is what i've decided to care about
for now model a does better they both
seem pretty good
and so maybe i'll choose model a to keep
working on maybe i'll choose it if you
were putting something into production
um but remember back to you know this
this idea that it's just one number to
summarize a very complex system uh it's
not going to be sufficient to tell you
how it's going to perform in a wide
variety of settings
okay so so we've been doing this this is
model evaluation as model analysis
um
now we're going to say what if we are
not testing on exactly the same type of
data that we trained on
so now we're asking did the model learn
something such that it's able to sort of
extrapolate or perform uh how i want it
to on data that looks a little bit
different from what it was trained on
and we're going to take the example of
natural language inference so to recall
the task of natural language inference
and this is through the multi-nli data
set that we're just pulling our
definition
you have a premise
he turned and saw john sleeping in his
half tent and you have a hypothesis
he saw john was asleep
and then you give them both to a model
and this is the model that we had before
that gets some good accuracy and the
model is supposed to tell whether
the hypothesis is sort of implied by the
premise or contradicting um so it could
be contradicting maybe if the hypothesis
is you know john was awake
for example or he saw john was awake
maybe that'd be a contradiction neutral
if sort of both could be true at the
same time so to speak and then
entailment in this case you know it
seems like they're saying that you know
the premise implies the hypothesis
and so um you know
you would say probably this is likely to
get the right answer since the accuracy
of the model is 95
95 of the time it gets the right answer
um and we're going to dig deeper into
that uh
what if the model is not doing what we
think we want it to be doing in order to
perform natural language inference
so in a data set like multi-nli the
authors who gathered the data set will
have
asked humans to perform the task and you
know gotten the accuracy that the humans
achieved and models nowadays are
achieving accuracies that are
around where humans are achieving um
which sounds great at first
but
as we'll see it's not the same as
actually performing the uh the task more
broadly in the right way
so what if the models not doing
something smart effectively
we're going to use a diagnostic test set
of carefully constructed examples that
seem like things the model should be
able to do
to test for a specific skill or capacity
in this case we'll use hans so hans is
the heuristic analysis for analyze
systems
data set and
it's intended to take systems that do
natural language inference and test
whether they're using some simple
syntactic heuristics
what we'll have in each of these cases
we'll have some heuristic
we'll talk through the definition we'll
get an example so the first thing is
lexical overlap so
the model might do this thing where it
assumes that a premise entails all
hypotheses constructed from words in the
premise so in this example you have um
the premise the doctor was paid by the
actor
and then the hypothesis is the doctor
paid the actor and you'll notice that in
bold here get the doctor okay and then
paid and then the actor
right and so if you use this
this heuristic you will think that the
doctor was paid by the actor implies the
doctor paid the actor that does not
imply it of course
and so you know you could expect a model
you want the model to be able to do this
it's somewhat simple
but if it's using this heuristic it
won't get this example right
next is uh subsequence uh heuristics so
here
at the prem if the model assumes that
the premise entails all of its
contiguous sub sequences it will get
this one wrong as well so this example
is the doctor near the actor danced
that's the premise the hypothesis is the
actor danced now this is a simple
syntactic thing the doctor is doing the
dancing near the actor is this
prepositional phrase
and so the model sort of uses this
heuristic oh look the actor dance that's
a subsequence entailed awesome then
it'll get this one wrong as well
and um
here's another one that's a lot like
subsequence but so if if the premise
if the model thinks that the premise
entails all
complete subtrees so this is like sort
of fully formed phrases so the artist
slept here is a fully formed sort of
it's a sub tree if the artist slept the
actor ran and then that's the premise
does it entail the hypothesis the actor
slept
uh
no
uh sorry the artist slept that does not
entail it because this is in that
conditional
okay i only pause here for some
questions before i
move on to see how these models do
anyone unclear about
how this sort of evaluation is being set
up
nope okay
cool okay
okay so um
so how do models perform that's sort of
the question of the hour um what we'll
do is uh
you know we'll look at these results
from the same paper that really released
the data set so they took four
strong multi-analyze models
with the following accuracies so the
accuracies here are something between 60
and you know 80 something 80 percent
bert over here is doing the best okay
and um
in domain right in that first sort of
setting that we talked about
uh you get these reasonable accuracies
and
that is sort of what we said before
about it like looking pretty good
and when we evaluate on hans
in this setting here
we have examples where the heuristics we
talked about
actually work so if the model is using
the heuristic it will get this right
and it gets
very high accuracies and then
if we evaluate the model in the settings
where if it uses the heuristic it gets
the examples wrong
um
you know maybe bert's doing like epsilon
better than some of the other stuff here
but it's uh it's it's it's a very
different story okay and you saw those
examples they're not
complex in our sort of own
idea of complexity
and so this is why it sort of feels like
a clear failure of the system
now you can say though that well maybe
the training data sort of wasn't didn't
have any of those sort of phenomena so
the model couldn't have learned uh not
to do that and that's sort of a
reasonable argument except well you know
bert is pre-trained on a bunch of
language text so you might hope you
might expect you might hope that it does
better
okay
so so we saw that example of um models
performing well on examples that are
like those that it was trained on and
then performing not very well at all on
examples that seem reasonable uh but are
um
sort of
a little bit tricky now we're going to
take this idea of having a test set that
we've carefully crafted and go in a
slightly different direction so we're
going to have what does it mean to try
to understand the linguistic properties
of our models does it so that syntactic
heuristics question was one thing for
natural language inference but can we
sort of test how the models whether they
think certain things are sort of right
or wrong
as language models
and the first way that we'll do this is
we'll ask well how do we think about
sort of what humans think of as good
language how do we evaluate
their sort of
preferences about language
and one answer is minimal pairs and the
idea of a minimal pair is that you've
got one sentence that sounds okay
to a speaker so this sentence is the
chef who made the pizzas is here
it's called it's an acceptable sentence
at least to me um and then with a small
change a minimal change um uh the
sentence is no longer okay to the
speaker so the chef who made the pizzas
are here
and um
this
whoops this should be
present tense verbs
in english present tense verbs agree in
number with their subject uh when they
are third person um so chef pizzas okay
um
and um
uh this is sort of a pretty general
thing most people don't like this it's a
misconjugated verb
and so the the syntax here looks like
you have the chef who made the pizzas
and then uh this arc of agreement and
number is requiring uh the word is here
to be singular is instead of plural are
despite the fact that there's this ver
this noun pizzas which is plural
closer linearly comes back to dependency
parsing we're back okay
um and what this this looks like in the
tree structure right is well you know
chef and is um are attached in the tree
um
you know chef is the subject of is
pizzas is down here in this sub tree
and so that subject-verb relationship
has this sort of agreement uh thing
so um this is a pretty sort of basic and
interesting property of language that
also reflects the syntactic sort of
hierarchical structure of language so
we've been training these language
models sampling from them seeing that
they get interesting things and they
tend to seem to generate syntactic
content
but does it really understand or does it
behave as if it understands this idea of
agreement more broadly and does it sort
of get the syntax right so that it
matches the subjects and the verbs
um so but language models can't tell us
exactly whether they think that a
sentence is good or bad they just tell
us the probability of a sentence uh so
um before we had acceptable and
unacceptable that's what we get from
humans um and the language models analog
is just does it assign higher
probability to the acceptable sentence
in the minimal pair right so you have
the probability under the model of um
the chef who made the made the pizzas is
here and then you have the probability
under the model of the chef maids that
made the pizzas are here and you want
this probability here to be higher
and if it is that's sort of like a a
simple way to test whether the model
like
got it right effectively
and
just like in hans
we can develop a test set with very
carefully chosen properties right so
most sentences in english don't have
terribly complex
subject-verb agreement structure with a
lot of words in the middle like pizzas
that are going to make it difficult so
if i say you know um the dog runs
sort of no way to get it wrong because
there's
no this index is very simple um so we
can create
or we can look for sentences that have
these the things called attractors
in the sentence so pizzas is an
attractor because the model might be
attracted to the plurality here and get
the conjugation wrong
so this is our question can language
models sort of very generally handle
these examples with attractors so we can
take examples with zero attractors see
whether the model gets the minimum pairs
evaluation right we can take examples
with one attractor
two attractors you can see how people
would still reasonably understand these
sentences right the chef who made the
pizzas and prep the ingredients is it's
still the chef who is
and then you know on and on and on it
gets rarer obviously but but you can
have more and more attractors
and so now we've created this test set
that's intended to evaluate this very
specific linguistic phenomenon
um so in this paper here concur it all
trained an lcm language model on a
subset of wikipedia
back in 2018 and they evaluate it sort
of in these buckets that are specified
by uh the paper
um the sort of
under introduced subject verb agreement
to uh
to the nlp field more recently at least
and they evaluate it in buckets based on
the number of attractors and so
in this table here that you're about to
see
the
the numbers are sort of the percent of
times that you get this assigned higher
probability to the correct uh
sentence in the minimal pair
so if you were just to do random or
majority class you get these errors oh
sorry it's the percent of times you get
it wrong
sorry about that so lower is better
um and so with no attractors you get
very low error rates so this is 1.3
error rate with a 350 dimensional lstm
um
and uh you know with uh with one
attractor your error rate is higher but
actually humans start to get errors with
more attractors too um so zero
attractors is easy
uh the larger the lstm it looks like in
general the better you're doing right so
the smaller models doing worse okay and
then even on sort of very difficult
examples with four attractors which
try to think of an example in your head
like the chef
made the pizzas and took out the trash
you know sort of has to be this long
sentence and the air rate is definitely
higher so it gets more difficult
but it's still it's still relatively low
and so even on these very hard examples
models are actually performing subject
verb number agreement relatively well
very
cool okay
uh here's some examples that a model got
wrong this is actually a worse model
than the ones from the paper that was
just there but i think actually the
errors are quite interesting
so here's a sentence the ship
that the player drives
has a very high speed
now this model thought that was less
probable than the ship that the player
drives have a very high speed
my
hypothesis right is that it sort of mis
analyzes drives as a plural
noun for example it's sort of a
difficult construction there i think
it's pretty interesting um
likewise here this one is so is is fun
uh the lead is also rather long
five paragraphs is pretty lengthy um so
here five paragraphs is a singular
noun together because it's like a unit
of length i guess um but
but the model thought that it was more
likely to say five paragraphs are pretty
lengthy um because it's referring to
this sort of
five paragraphs as the five
actual paragraphs themselves as opposed
to a single unit of length describing
the lead
fascinating
okay
um
maybe questions again
so i guess there are a couple
can we do the similar heuristic analysis
for other tasks such as q a
classification
yes um
so yes i think that it's easier to do
this kind of analysis
for
like the hans style analysis with uh
with question answering um
and other other sorts of tasks because
you can construct examples that
similarly
uh
you know have these
heuristics um
[Music]
uh and then have the answer depend on
the syntax or not you know the actual
probability of one
sentence is higher than the other of
course is sort of a language model
dependent thing but um the idea that you
can sort of like
develop kind of bespoke test sets for
various tasks um
i think is very very general and um
something i think is actually quite uh
quite interesting um
yes so
i won't i'll go on further but i think
the answer is just yes
so there's another one
um how do you know where to find these
failure cases maybe that's the right
time to advertise linguistics classes
sorry uh
you're still very quiet over here
how do you find what
how do you know where to find these
failure cases
oh interesting yes how do we know where
to find the failure cases
that's a good question i mean i think i
agree with chris that actually
you know thinking about what is
uh
interesting about things in language is
one way to do it i mean the kind of the
heuristics that we saw
in our language model sorry in our nli
models with hans
you can kind of imagine that they
if the model was sort of ignoring facts
about language and sort of just doing
this sort of rough bag of words with
some extra magic then it would do well
about as bad as it's doing here and
these sorts of ideas about
you know
understanding that this statement if the
artist slept the actor ran does not
imply the artist slept is the kind of
thing that um maybe you'd think up on
your own but also you'd spend time sort
of pondering about and and and thinking
broad thoughts about in uh in you know
linguistics curricula as well so
uh anything else chris
um so there's
also well i guess someone was also
saying i think it's about the sort of
intervening verbs example or intervening
noun sorry example but the data so the
data set itself probably includes
mistakes with higher attractors
yeah yeah that's a good point um
yeah because humans make more and more
mistakes as the number of attractors
gets larger
um on the other hand i think that the
mistakes are fewer in written text than
in spoken
maybe i'm just making that up but that's
what i think
um but yeah it would be interesting to
actually go through that test set and
see
how many of the errors the really strong
model makes are actually due to
the sort of observed form being
incorrect i'd be super curious
okay
should i move on
yep
great
okay
so um
so so what does it feel like we're doing
when we are kind of constructing these
sort of bespoke small careful test sets
for various phenomena well it it sort of
feels like unit testing
and in fact this sort of idea has been
brought in brought to the fore you might
say an nlp
unit tests but for these nlp neural
networks and in particular uh the paper
here that i'm sitting at the bottom
suggests this minimal function a minimum
functionality test you want a small test
set that targets a specific behavior
that should sound like some of the
things that we were that we've already
talked about but in this case
we're going to get even more specific
so here's a single test case we're going
to have
an expected label what was actually
predicted whether the model passed this
unit test
and the labels are going to be this is
going to be sentiment analysis here so
negative label positive label or neutral
or the three options
and the unit test is going to consist
simply of uh sentences that follow this
template i then negation the positive
verb and then the thing
so if you if you negation positive verb
means you negative verb right and so
here's an example i can't say i
recommend the food the expected label is
negative the answer that the model
provided and this is i think a
commercial
sentiment analysis system i was paused
so it predicted positive and then i
didn't love the flight it the expected
label was negative and then the
predicted answer was uh neutral
and this
commercial sentiment analysis system
gets a lot of
well you could imagine are pretty
reasonably simple examples wrong and so
um what rbiro all 2020 showed is that
they could actually provide a system um
that sort of had this framework of
building test cases for nlp models two
ml engineers working on these products
um
and uh give them that interface and they
would
actually
find bugs
you know bugs being categories of high
error right find bugs in their models
that they could then kind of try to go
and fix and that this was kind of an
efficient way of trying to find things
that were simple and still wrong with
what should be pretty
pretty sophisticated neural systems
so i really like this and
it's sort of a nice way of thinking more
specifically about what are the
capabilities um in in sort of precise
terms of our models
and all together now you've seen
problems in uh
natural language inference
you've seen language models actually
perform pretty well at the language
modeling objective but then you see uh
you just saw an example of a commercial
sentiment analysis system sort of should
do better and doesn't and um this comes
to this really i think broad and
important takeaway which is uh
if you get high accuracy on the
in-domain test set
you are not guaranteed high accuracy on
even what you might consider to be
reasonable out of domain evaluations and
life is always out of domain
and if you're building a system that
will be
given to users
it's immediately out of domain at the
very least because it's trained on text
that's now older than the things that
the users are now saying so it's a
really really important takeaway that
your sort of benchmark accuracy is a
single number that does not guarantee
good performance on a wide variety of
things and from a what are our neural
networks doing perspective one way to
think about it is that models seem to be
learning the data set fitting sort of
the fine-grained
sort of heuristics and statistics that
help it
fit this one data set as opposed to
learning the tasks so humans can perform
natural language inference if you give
them examples from whatever data set
you know once you've told them how to do
the task they'll be very generally
strong at it
but you take your mli
model and you test it on hans and it got
you know whatever that was below chance
accuracy that's not the kind of thing
that you want to see so it definitely
learns the data set well because the
accuracy in domain is high
but our models are
seemingly not
frequently learning uh sort of the
mechanisms that we would like them to be
learning
last week we heard about language models
and sort of the implicit knowledge that
they encode about the world through
pre-training and
one of the ways that we sought interact
with language models was providing them
with a prompt
like dante was born in mask
and then seeing if it puts high
probability on the correct continuation
which requires you to access knowledge
about where dante was born and we didn't
frame it this way last week but this
fits into the set of behavioral studies
that we've done so far this is a
specific kind of input
you could ask this for multiple types of
multiple people you could swap out dante
for other people who swapped out born in
for
i don't know died in or something um and
then you can
they're like test suites again and so um
it's all connected okay so i won't go
too deep into sort of the knowledge of
language models in terms of world
knowledge because we've
gone over it some but you know when
you're thinking about ways of
interacting with your models
this sort of behavioral study can be
very very general
even though remember we're at still this
highest level of abstraction uh where
we're just looking at the probability
distributions that are defined
all right
so now we'll go into so we've sort of
looked at understanding in in
fine-grained areas what our model is
actually doing um
uh what about sort of why for an
individual input is it getting the
answer right or wrong and then are there
changes to the inputs that look fine to
humans but actually make the models uh
do a bad job so one study that i love to
reference that really draws back into
our our original motivation of using
lstm networks instead of simple
recurrent neural networks was that they
could use long context
so
but like how long is your long short
term memory and the idea of kindle
kindlewell at all 2018 was
shuffle or remove contexts that are
farther than some k words away
changing k
and
if the accuracy if the if the predictive
ability of your language model the
perplexity right doesn't change once you
do that it means the model wasn't
actually using that context i think this
is so cool so
on the x-axis we've got how far away
from the word that you're trying to
predict are you actually sort of
corrupting shuffling or removing stuff
from the from the sequence and then on
the y-axis is the increase in loss so if
the increase in loss is zero
it means that the model
was not using the thing that you just
removed because if it was using it it
would now do worse without it right and
so in uh if you shuffle in the blue line
here if you shuffle the history that's
farther away from 50 words the model
does not even notice
i think that's really interesting one it
says everything past 50 words of this
lstm language model
you could have given it in random order
and it wouldn't have noticed
uh
and then two it says that if you're
closer than that it actually is making
use of the word order that's a pretty
long memory okay that's really
interesting and then if you actually
remove the words entirely
you have you can kind of notice that the
words are missing up to 200 words away
so you don't know the order that you
don't care about the order they're in
but you care whether they're there or
not and so this is
an evaluation of well do lstms have
long-term memory well this one at least
has effectively no longer than 200 words
of
of memory
but also no less
so
very cool
um
so that's like a general study for a
single model it talks about
uh it's it's sort of average behavior
over a wide range of examples but we
want to talk about individual
predictions on individual inputs so
let's talk about that so um
one way of interpreting why did my model
make this decision that's very popular
is for a single example what parts of
the input actually led to the decision
and this is where we come in with
saliency maps so a saliency map
provides a score for each word
indicating its importance to the model's
prediction so you've got something like
bert here you've got bert bert is making
a prediction for this mask
the mask rushed to the emergency room to
see her patient
okay and so and the predictions that the
model is making is things with 47 it's
going to be nurse that's here in the
mask
instead or maybe woman or doctor or
mother or girl okay
and then the saliency map is being
visualized here in orange according to
this method of saliency called simple
gradients which we'll get into emergency
her
and the sep token
let's not worry about the step token for
now but emergency in her are the
important words apparently and the sub
token shows up in every sentence so i'm
not gonna yeah um right and so these two
together are
according to this method what's
important for the model to make this
prediction to mask
and you can see you know maybe some
statistics biases etc that is picked up
in the predictions and then have it
mapped out onto the sentence and this is
well it seems like it's really helping
interpretability um
and uh um
yeah i think that this is sort of a a
very useful tool and actually this is
part of a demo from alan nlp uh that
allows you to do this um
uh yourself for any sentence that you
want um so what's this what's this way
of making saliency maps we're not going
to go there's there's so many ways to do
it we're going to take a very simple one
and work through why it sort of makes
sense um
so
the sort of issue is how do you define
importance
right what does it mean to be important
to the model's prediction um and here's
one way of thinking about it it's called
the simple gradient method uh let's get
a little formal you've got words x1 to
xn
okay and then you've got a model score
for a given output class so maybe you've
got
in the birch example each output class
was each output word that you could
possibly predict
um and then you take the norm
of the gradient of the score with
respect to each word okay so so what
we're saying here is
the score
right is sort of the unnormalized
probability
um
for that for that class
okay so you got a single class you're
taking the score it's like how likely it
is not yet normalized by how likely
everything else is sort of um gradient
how much is it going to change
if i move it a little bit in one
direction or another and then you take
the norm to get a scalar from a vector
so it looks like this so salience of
word i
you have the norm bars on the outside
gradient with respect to x i
so that's if i change a little bit
locally x i
how much does my score change
um so the idea is that a high gradient
norm means that if i were to change it
locally i'd affect the score a lot and
that means it was very important to the
decision let's visualize this a little
bit so
here on the y-axis we've got loss just
the loss of the model sorry this should
be score
it should be score and on the x-axis
you've got word space
and the word space is like sort of a
flattening of
the ability to move your word embedding
in thousand dimensional space i've just
plotted it here in one dimension
um
and now a high saliency thing you can
see that the relationship between
what should be score and moving the word
in word space you move it a little bit
on the x-axis and the score changes a
lot that's that derivative that's the
gradient awesome love it uh low saliency
you move the word around locally and uh
the the score doesn't change
so that's an interpreter the
interpretation
is that means that the actual you know
identity of this word wasn't that
important to the prediction because i
could have changed it and the score
wouldn't have changed
now why are there more methods than this
because i'm honestly reading that i was
like that sounds awesome that sounds
great you know there are sort of a lots
of issues with this kind of
method and lots of ways of getting
around them here's one issue
it's not perfect
because well maybe your linear
approximation that the gradient gives
you holds only very very locally right
so here the gradient is zero so this is
a low saliency word because at the
bottom of this parabola but if i were to
move even a little bit in either
direction the score would like shoot up
right so is this not an important word
like it seems
important to be right there
as opposed to anywhere else even sort of
nearby
in order for the score not to go up so
but the the simple gradients method
won't capture this because it just looks
at the gradient which is that zero right
there
okay
but uh if you want to look into more
there's a bunch of different methods
that are sort of applied in these papers
and um you know i think that there's a
good tool for the toolbox
okay so um
that is one way of explaining a
prediction and
um
you know has some issues like
why are individual words being scored as
opposed to phrases or something like
that um and but for now we're going to
move on to another type of explanation
and i'm gonna check the time okay cool
um actually yeah let me pause for a
second any questions about this
ah
i mean earlier on there were a couple of
questions
one of them was what are your thoughts
what are your thoughts on whether
looking at attention weights is a
methodologically rigorous way of
determining the importance that the
model places on certain tokens it seems
like there's some back and forth in the
literature
that is a
that's a great question and i probably
won't engage with that question as much
as
i could if we had like a second lecture
on this i actually will provide some
attention analyses and tell you they're
interesting and then i'll sort of say a
little bit about um
uh
you know
why they can be interesting without
being sort of uh
maybe
um
sort of the end-all of analysis of of uh
where information is flowing in a
transformer for example um i think the
debate is
something that we would have to get into
in a much longer period of time but look
at the slides that i show about
attention and the caveats that i provide
and let me know if that answers your
question first because we have quite a
number of slides on it and if not please
please ask again and we can chat more
about it
and maybe you can go on
great okay so um
i think this is a really fascinating
question which also gets at what was
important about the input
but in actually kind of an even more
direct way which is could i just keep
some minimal part of the input and get
the same answer so here's an example
from squad
you have this passage in 1899 john jacob
ashton iv invested 100 000
for tesla okay
and then the answer that is being
predicted by the model is going to
always be in blue in these examples
colorado springs experiments so you've
got this passage
and the question is what did tesla spend
astr's money on that's why the
prediction is colorado springs
experiments the model gets the
answer right which is nice and we would
like to think it's because it's doing
some kind of reading comprehension
but here's the issue
it turns out based on this fascinating
paper
that if you just recruit reduce the
question to
did
you actually get exactly the same
you actually get exactly the same answer
and in fact with the original question
the model had sort of a 0.78
confidence you know probability in that
answer and uh with the with the reduced
question did
you get even higher confidence and that
if you give a human this they would not
be able to know really what you're
trying to ask about so it seems like
some things are going really wonky here
here's another so here here's sort of
like a very high level overview of the
method
in fact it actually references our input
sale and same methods nice it's
connected so so um you iteratively
remove
non-salient or unimportant words so
here's a quest here's a passage again
talking about football um i think yeah
and uh and oh nice okay so the question
is where did the broncos practice for
the super bowl as the prediction of
stanford university
um
and that is correct so again seems nice
and now we're not actually going to you
know get the model to be incorrect we're
just going to say
um
how can i change this question
such that i still get the answer right
so i'm going to remove the word that was
least important according to a saliency
method so now it's where did the
practice for the super bowl
already this is sort of unanswerable
because you've got two teams practicing
you don't even know which one you're
asking about so why the model still
thinks it's so confident in stanford
university makes no sense but you can
just sort of keep
going
and you know now i think
here the model stops being confident in
the answer stanford university
but you know
i think this is really interesting just
to show that
if the model is able to do this with
very high confidence
it's not reflecting the uncertainty that
really should be there because you can't
know what you're even asking about
okay so what was important to make this
answer well
at least this part these parts were
important because you could keep just
those parts and get the same answer
fascinating
um all right so that's sort of the end
of the admittedly brief uh section on
thinking about uh input saliency methods
and similar things now we're going to
talk about actually breaking models and
understanding models by breaking them
okay cool um so if we have a passage
here peyton manning became the first
quarterback
um
[Music]
something super bowl age 39 past record
held by john elway uh again we're doing
question answering we've got this
question what was the name of the
quarterback who was 38 in the super bowl
the prediction is correct looks good now
we're not going to change the question
to try to uh sort of make the question
nonsensical while keeping the same
answer instead we're going to change the
passage
um
by adding the sentence at the end which
really shouldn't distract anyone this is
quarterback well-known quarterback jeff
dean you know had jersey number 37 in
champ bowl so this just doesn't it's
really not even related
but now the prediction is jeff dean uh
for our nice qa model um and so this
shows as well that
um it seems like maybe there's this like
end of the passage bias as to what where
the answer should be for example and so
not that's this is an adversarial
example where we flipped the prediction
by adding something that is innocuous to
humans
and so sort of like the higher level
takeaway is like oh it seems like the qa
model that we had that seemed good it's
not actually performing qa how we want
it to even though it's in domain
accuracy it was good um
and uh here's another example so you've
got this this paragraph
with a question what has been the result
of this publicity uh the answer is
increased scrutiny on teacher misconduct
now instead of changing the paragraph
we're going to change the question in
really really
seemingly
insignificant ways to change the model's
prediction so first
what h.a and now you've got this type o
l been the result of this publicity the
answer changes to teacher misconduct
likely a human would sort of ignore this
typo or something and answer the right
answer and then this is really nuts
instead of asking what has been the
result of this publicity if you ask
what's been the result of this publicity
the answer also changes
and this is
the the authors call this a semantically
equivalent adversary uh this is pretty
rough and in general uh swapping what
for what's in this qa model breaks it
pretty frequently
and so again when you go back and sort
of
re-tinker how to build your model
you're going to be thinking about these
things not just the sort of average
accuracy
um so
that's sort of talking about noise our
models robust to noise in their inputs
our humans robust to noise there's
another question we can ask and so you
can kind of go to this popular
sort of meme passed around the internet
from time to time where you have all the
letters in these words scrambled you say
according to a research uh
or at cambridge university it doesn't
matter in what order the letters in a
word are right and so it seems like you
know
i think i did a pretty good job there uh
seemingly right we got this noise that's
a specific kind of noise and we can be
robust as humans to reading and
processing the language
without actually all that much of a
difficulty um so that's maybe something
that we might want our models to also be
robust to
and
it's it's very practical as well noise
is a part of all nlp systems
inputs at all times there's just no such
thing effectively as having you know
users for example and not having any
noise um
and so there's a study that was
performed on some you know popular
machine translation models where you
train machine translation models french
german and czech i think all to english
and you get blue scores these blue
scores will look a lot better than the
ones in your simon 4 because much much
more training data the idea is these are
actually pretty strong machine
translation systems
and that's in in domain clean text
now if you add character swaps like the
ones we saw in you know in that in that
sentence about cambridge
the blue scores take a pretty harsh dive
not very good
and even if you take somewhat a somewhat
more natural sort of typo
noise distribution here
you'll see that you're still getting you
know 20-ish
yeah very high
drops in blue score through simply
natural noise
and so maybe you'll go back and retrain
the model on more types of noise and
then you ask oh if i do that is it
robust to even different kinds of noise
these are the questions that are going
to be really important and it's
important to know that you're able to
break your model really easily so you
can then go and try to make it more
robust
okay um now let's see
20 minutes
ah some
uh now we're going to
i guess yeah
yeah so now we're going to look at the
representations of our neural networks
we've talked about sort of their
behavior and then whether we could sort
of change or observe reasons behind
their behavior now we'll
go into less abstraction
look more at the actual vector
representations that are being built by
models and we can answer a different
kind of question
at the very least than with the other
studies
the first thing is related to the
question that was asked about attention
which is that um some modeling
components lend themselves to inspection
now this is a sentence that i chose
somewhat carefully actually because in
part of this debate right
are they interpretable components
we'll see but they lend themselves to
inspection in the following way you can
visualize them well and you can
correlate them easily with various
properties
so let's say you have attention heads in
bert this is from a really
nice study that was done here
where
you look at intention heads of burt and
you say
you know on most sentences this
attention head had one one seems to do
this very sort of global aggregation
simple kind of operation does this
pretty consistently that's cool um is it
interpretable
well
maybe right so it's the first layer
which means that this word found
is sort of uncontextualized
and then um you know but in deeper
layers the problem is that like once you
do some rounds of attention you've had
information mixing and flowing between
words and how do you know exactly what
information you're combining what you're
attending to even it's a little hard to
tell
and saliency methods more directly sort
of evaluate the importance of models but
it's still interesting to see
at sort of a local mechanistic point of
view what kinds of things are being
attended to
so so let's take another example some
attention heads seem to perform simple
operations so you have the global
aggregation here that we saw already
others seem to attend pretty robustly to
the next token cool next token is a
great signal some heads attend to the
sep token
uh so here you have attending to sep and
then maybe some attend to periods maybe
that's sort of a
you know splitting sentences together
and things like that not things that are
hard to do but things that some
attention heads seem to pretty robustly
perform
um
again now though deep in the network
what's actually represented at this
period at
layer 11
a little unclear a little unclear okay
so
some heads though are correlated with
really interesting linguistic properties
so this head is actually attending to
noun modifiers so you've got this the
complicated
language
in the huge new
law
right that's pretty fascinating
even if the model is not like
doing this as a causal mechanism to do
syntax necessarily the fact that these
things so strongly correlate is actually
pretty pretty cool and so we have in all
of these studies is we've got sort of an
approximate interpretation and
quantitative analysis
relating uh like allowing us to reason
about very complicated model behavior
they're all approximations but they're
they're definitely interesting uh one
other example is that of co-reference so
we saw some work on co-ref reference and
um it seems like this head does a pretty
okay job of actually matching up
co-referent entities these are in red
talks negotiations she her and that's
not obvious how to do that this is a
difficult task and so it does so you
know with some percentage of the time
um
and again it's sort of connecting very
complex model behavior to
uh
to these sort of interpretable summaries
of correlating uh properties
other cases you can have individual
hidden units that lend themselves to
interpretation
so
here you've got a character level lstm
language model
each row here is a sentence if you can't
read it it's totally okay the
interpretation that you should take is
that as we walk along the sentence this
single unit is going from i think
very negative to very positive or very
positive to very negative i don't really
remember
but it's you know tracking the position
in the line
so it's just a linear position unit and
uh
pretty robustly doing so across all of
these sentences
so this is from a nice visualization
study way back in 2016 way back
here's another cell from that same lstm
language model that seems to sort of
turn on
inside quotes so here's a quote
and it turns on okay so i guess that's
positive in the blue
end quote here
and then it's negative
here you start with no quote
negative in the red see a quote
and then blue seems again very
interpretable also potentially a very
useful feature to keep in mind and this
is just an individual unit in the lstm
that you can just look at and see that
it does this very very interesting
even farther on this and this is
actually a study by some
ai and neuroscience researchers is okay
we saw that lstms were good at subject
verb number agreement um can we figure
out the mechanisms by which the lstm is
solving the task can we actually get
some insight into that and so we have a
word level language model
the word level language model is going
to be a little small but you have a
sentence the boy gently and kindly
greets the
and this cell that's being tracked here
so it's an individual hidden unit um one
dimension right is actually after it
sees boy it sort of starts to go
higher and then it goes down to
something very small once it sees greets
and this cell seems to correlate with
the scope of a subject verb number
agreement
instance effectively so here the boy
that watches the dog that watches the
cat greets
you've got that cell again staying high
maintaining the scope of subject until
greets and at which point it stops
what allows it to do that probably some
complex other
dynamics in the network but it's still a
fascinating i think insight
um and yeah this is just you know neuron
1150 in this lstm
now
so those are sort of all observational
studies that you could do
by picking out individual components of
the model that you can sort of just take
each one of
and
correlating them with some behavior now
we'll look at a general class of methods
called probing
by which we still sort of use supervised
knowledge like
the knowledge of the type of
co-reference that we're looking for but
instead of seeing if it correlates with
something that's immediately
interpretable like a
attention head we're going to look into
the vector representations of the model
and see if these properties can be read
out by some simple function
to say oh maybe this property was made
very easily accessible by my neural
network so let's dig into this
so the general paradigm is that you've
got language data uh that goes into some
big pre-trained transformer with
fine-tuning and you get state-of-the-art
results uh soda means state-of-the-art
right and so the question for the
probing sort of methodology is like if
it's providing these general purpose
language representations you know
what does it actually encode about
language
like
can we can we quantify this can we
figure out what kinds of things is
learning about language that we
seemingly now don't have to tell it
and um so you might have something like
a sentence like i record the record
that's an interesting sentence and you
put it into your your transformer model
with its word embeddings at the be at
the beginning maybe some layers of
self-attention and stuff and you make
some predictions and now our objects of
study are going to be these intermediate
layers
right so it's a vector per word
or sub word uh for every layer
and the question is like can we use
these linguistic properties like the
dependency parsing that we had way back
in the early part of the course um to
understand uh sort of correlations
between
properties and the vectors and these
things that we can interpret we can
interpret dependency parses
so so there are a couple of things that
we might want to look for here
you might want to look for semantics so
here in the sentence i record the record
uh i am an agent that's a semantics
thing uh
record is a patient it's the thing i'm
recording okay you might have syntax so
you might have the syntax tree that
you're interested in that's the
dependency parse tree
maybe you're interested in part of
speech right because you have record uh
and record and uh the first one's a verb
the second one is a noun they're
identical strings does the model sort of
encode that one is one and the other is
the other um so how do we do this kind
of study um so we're going to decide on
a layer that we want to analyze
and we're going to freeze burt the we're
not going to fine-tune bird all the
parameters are frozen
so we decide on layer two of bert we're
gonna pass it some sentences we decide
on a on a what's called a probe family
and the question i'm asking is can i use
a model from my family say linear to
decode a property that i'm interested in
really well from this layer
so it's
indicating that this property is easily
accessible to
linear models effectively so maybe i get
i train a model i train a linear
classifier right on top of bert
and i get a really high
accuracy and that's sort of interesting
already because you know
from prior work and part of speech
tagging that if you run a linear
classifier on simpler features that
aren't burnt you probably don't get as
high in accuracy so that's an
interesting sort of takeaway but then
you can also take like a baseline so i
want to compare two layers now so i've
got layer one here i want to compare it
to layer two
i train a probe on it as well maybe the
accuracy isn't as good and now i can say
oh wow look by layer 2 part of speech is
more easily accessible to linear
functions than it was at layer 1.
so what did that well the self-attention
and feed forward stuff made it more
easily accessible that's interesting
because it's a statement about sort of
the information processing of the model
okay
okay so that's we're going to analyze
these layers let's take a second more to
think about it
and just really give me just a second
so if you have the model's
representations h1 to ht
and you have a function family f that's
the subset linear models or maybe you
have like a feed forward neural network
some fixed set of hyper parameters
freeze the model
train the probe so you get some
predictions for part of speech tagging
or whatever that's just the probe
applied to the hidden state of the model
the probe was a member of the probe
family
and then the extent that we can predict
why is a measure of accessibility so
that's just kind of written out not as
pictorially okay
so i'm not going to
not going to
stay on this for too much longer
and
you know it may help in the search for
causal mechanisms
but it sort of just gives us a rough
understanding of
sort of processing of the model and what
things are accessible at what layer
so what are some results here so one
result is that
bert if you run linear probes on it does
really really well on things that
require syntax and part of speech named
entity recognition actually in some
cases approximately as well as just
doing the very best thing you could
possibly do
without without bert so it just makes
easily accessible amazingly strong
features for these properties and that's
an interesting sort of
emergent quality of burt you might say
it seems like as well that the layers of
bert
have this property where so if you look
at the columns of this of this
plot here each column is a task
you've got input words at the sort of
layer zero albert here layer 24 is the
last layer of bur at large
lower performance is yellow higher
performance is blue and io the
resolution isn't perfect but
consistently the best place to read out
these properties is somewhere a bit past
the middle of the model
uh which is this is a very consistent
rule which is fascinating
um
and then it seems as well like uh if you
look at this function of increasingly
abstract or increasingly difficult to
compute linguistic properties on this
axis and increasing depth in the network
on that axis
so the deeper you go in the network it
seems like the more
easily you can access more and more
abstract linguistic properties
suggesting that that accessibility is
being constructed over time by the
layers of processing of bert so it's
building more and more abstract features
which i think is again sort of really
interesting result
um and now i think
yeah one thing that i think comes to
mind uh that really brings us back right
to day one
is um we built intuitions around word to
back we were asking like what does each
dimension of word to vec mean and the
answer was uh not really not really
anything but we could
build intuitions about it and think
about properties of it through sort of
these connections between simple
mathematical properties of word to vect
and linguistic properties that we could
sort of understand
so we had this approximation just not
not 100 true but an approximation that
says cosine similarity
is effectively
correlated with semantic similarity
think about even if all we're going to
do at the end of the day is fine tune
these word embeddings anyway um likewise
we had this sort of idea about the
analogies being encoded by linear
offsets so some relationships
are linear in space
and they didn't have to be that's
fascinating it's this emergent property
that we've now been able to study since
we discovered this why is that the case
in word to vec and in general even
though you can't interpret the
individual dimensions of of word to back
these sort of emergent interpretable
connections between
approximate linguistic ideas and sort of
simple math on these objects is
fascinating and so one piece of work
that sort of extends this idea um comes
back to dependency parse trees so they
describe the syntax of sentences um and
in a paper uh that i did with uh with
chris um
[Music]
we showed that actually bert and models
like it uh make dependency parse tree
structure emergent uh sort of more
easily accessible than one might imagine
in its vector space
so if you've got a tree right here the
chef who rented the store was out of
food
what you can sort of do is think about
the tree in terms of
distances between words so you've got
the number of edges in the tree between
two words is their path distance so
you've got sort of that the distance
between chef and was is one and we're
going to use this interpretation of a
tree as a distance to make a connection
with bert's embedding space and what we
were able to show is that under a single
linear transformation
the squared euclidean distance between
bert vectors for the same sentence
actually correlates well if you choose
the b matrix right
with the distances in the tree so here
in this euclidean space that we've
transformed
the approximate distance between chef
and was is also one
likewise the difference between was and
store is four in the tree
and in my simple sort of transformation
of bert space the distance between store
and was is also approximately four and
this is true across a wide range of
sentences and this is like to me a
fascinating
example of again emergent approximate
structure in these very non-linear
models that don't necessarily need to
encode things so simply
okay
all right
great so um
probing studies and correlation studies
are i think interesting and point us in
directions to build intuitions about
models
but they're not arguments that the model
is actually using the thing that you're
finding to make a decision
not causal studies
this is for probing and correlation
studies so
in some work that i did
around the same time we showed actually
that certain conditions on probes allow
you to achieve high accuracy on a task
that's effectively just fitting random
labels
and so there's a difficulty of an inter
of interpret
interpreting what the model could or
could not be doing with this thing that
is somehow easily accessible it's
interesting that this property is easily
accessible but the model might not be
doing anything with it for example
because it's totally random
likewise another paper showed that you
can achieve high accuracy with a probe
even if the model is trained to know
that thing that you're probing for is
not useful
um and there's causal studies that sort
of try to extend this work it's much
more difficult but read this paper and
it's a fascinating line of future work
now in my last you know two minutes um i
want to talk about or casting model
tweaks and ablations as analysis
um so we had this improvement process
where we had a network that was going to
work okay and we would see whether we
could tweak it in simple ways to improve
it and then you could see whether you
could remove anything and have it still
be okay and that's kind of like analysis
like i have my network do i want it to
like is it going to be better if it's
more complicated if it's going to be
better if it's simpler can i get away
with it being simpler
and so one example of some folks who did
this is they took this idea of
multi-headed attention and said
so many heads all the head's important
and what they showed is that if you
train a system with multi-headed
attention and then just remove the heads
at test time and not use them at all you
can actually do pretty well on the
original task not retraining at all
without some of the attention heads
showing that they weren't important you
could just get rid of them after
training and likewise you can do the
same thing for this is our machine
translation this is on multi-nli you can
actually get away without a large large
percentage of your attention heads
uh let's see
yeah so um
another thing that you could think about
is questioning sort of the the basics of
the models that we're building so we
have transformer models that are sort of
self-attention feed forward
self-attention feed forward but like why
in that order with some of the things
emitted here and the uh this paper asked
this question and said if this is my
transformer self-attention feed forward
self-attention feed forward etc etc etc
uh what if i just reordered it so that i
had a bunch of self-attentions at the
head and a bunch of feed forwards at the
back and they tried a bunch of these
orderings and this one actually does uh
better so this achieves a lower
perplexity on a benchmark and this is a
way of analyzing what's important about
the architectures that i'm building and
how can they be changed in order to
perform better
so neural models are very complex and
they're difficult to characterize and
impossible to characterize with a single
sort of statistic i think for your test
set accuracy especially in domain
and we want to find intuitive
descriptions of model behaviors
but we should look at multiple levels of
abstraction and none of them are going
to be complete
when someone tells you that their neural
network is interpretable i encourage you
to engage critically with that
it's not necessarily false but like the
levels of interpretability and what you
can interpret these are the questions
that you should be asking because it's
going to be opaque in some ways almost
definitely
um and then you know bring this sort of
i this this this lens to your model
building as you try to think about how
to build better models even if you're
not going to be doing analysis as sort
of one of your main driving goals
uh and with that you know good luck on
your final projects i realize we're at
time um the teaching staff is really
appreciative of of your efforts um over
this difficult quarter and uh yeah hope
so
um yeah i guess there's a lecture left
on thursday but yeah
this is my last one so thanks everyone